people come and visit here they all say  the same thing it's so peaceful  it's good you know let me somebody love  you  see my brother and your sister I don't  know that's beat us  where are we going somewhere I can shoot  something  [Music]  [Music]  there are six sets of tracer someone  helps someone cover up the tracks I  [Music]  don't know who done it but I think it  was someone pissed off I want you to  work these woods about a hundred yards  out  [Music]  I'm glad that my daughter has found  someone who'd be able to take care of  her what did you and Ray do last night  we went home with a bit we had a flat  Phil did Norman ever tell you that it  was a cover-up  you got something to tell me ring  we smiled at each other like oz just you  should have taken me in look it what do  telling him now  what happened I'll be here between ray  and my sister when it comes to  protection  nothing loves you like your own flesh  and blood  you